[MUSIC PLAYING]
LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live.
Louis Gray here from Mountain
View Google headquarters here
in California with my good
friend, Brian Fitzpatrick,
who's come down from Chicago
for the third in a set of
three shows that we're calling,
"Fitz Week." Today--
you laugh.
I like Fitz Week.
Today we're talking about
something that's actually near
and dear to all of our users
and everyone who wants to
understand what's happening
in the world of data.
We're talking about the
Transparency Report.
So let's just start from the
very beginning, Fitz, and talk
about the Google Transparency
Report, which anybody can find
at
google.com/transparencyreport.
What is this all about?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So the
Transparency Report
started as a way to--
you know, it's called
Transparency Report, but it's
almost like an accountability
report.
The original goal of it is to
show how powerful entities are
affecting the free flow of
information on the internet.
And it has continued
to expand to cover
more interesting things.
And initially it was just
governments, and now it's
starting to show how things
like a civil request like
copyright takedowns are
affecting the free flow of
information, as well as things
like malware and
that kind of thing.
LOUIS GRAY: And you mentioned
copyright takedowns.
The traffic report, I think,
is the one that's the most
visible in terms of possibly
services being impacted.
What are the specific pieces
within the Transparency Report
that are displayed?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: So starting
with traffic, which is very,
as you say, is the
most visible.
It's interesting, because
you get these graphs.
And what they are basically is
graphs of traffic in near-real
time, only a two minute delay
of traffic from our products
to various countries around the
world, over 100 countries.
So there's an aggregate
all-products traffic which
shows basically all the traffic
we're seeing from any
given country.
And then there's-- we
divide up by several
of our bigger products--
YouTube, Blogger, Google Search,
that sort of thing.
And if you look at one of these
graphs, let's say for
the past couple weeks, it looks
a little bit like a
heart rate monitor,
like an EKG.
There's this sort of bump,
a peak where peak
traffic for the day.
And then it goes down, and
there's a smaller peak.
And then there's a trough at
night when people are--
late at night, or early in the
morning when people are
sleeping in that country.
And so that's a normal
pattern you see.
We call it the heartbeat.
And there are cases where
internet service is
interrupted, and that's
when it goes flat.
And we initially watched this
to show when countries were
cutting access to
Google products.
The popular thing was some
countries cut off access to
Blogger, because people were
saying things on blogs they
didn't like.
Other countries were cutting
access to YouTube, because
they didn't like some
of the things
that YouTube was showing.
And it wasn't until the Arab
Spring happened in Egypt that
a country completely cut
off the internet.
And suddenly, we realized that
we were showing, basically,
internet traffic to a country.
And so we became a
reporter on that.
And at the time when that
happened, initially we were
delaying our graphs 35 hours,
because it takes us about that
long to verify and make
sure that all
of our data is correct.
We actually did a lot of work,
our team did a lot of work to
get that down to under
two minutes now.
So we're sort of part
of the story.
So when somebody cuts their
internet traffic, we show it
rather quickly, in under
a couple of minutes.
LOUIS GRAY: And the Transparency
Report shows not
just government interruptions,
but you mentioned like network
interruptions via a cut cable
somewhere, a data center
that's been hit by a meteor,
multiple data centers that
were hit by meteors, or other
things that impact the uptime
of our own products.
And that's also displayed
there.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Right.
I mean, so the point around this
is that this tends to be,
when the internet's cut off,
an extra-legal event.
So it's done outside
of typical law.
It's sort of if somebody pulls
the plug on the internet.
Like the way Egypt worked is
they literally shut down the
breakers in the Ramses
international telephone
exchange in Cairo.
But there are other-- cable
cut is an example.
We saw 50% decrease in traffic
to Armenia, I believe it was,
on a Sunday for five hours.
And then it came back
just like normal.
And there was no unrest.
There was nothing
weird happening.
We were completely confused
until the next day.
We saw that there was
a woman had been
stealing copper cables.
And she cut through a fiber
cable and looked at it and
said, oh, this isn't copper,
and then walked away.
There's actually a picture of
this woman holding a saw.
It's pretty amazing.
But what that means is that,
despite the fact that the
internet routes around failures,
you've only got one
or two ingress or egress points
for your internet
connection.
That's a bad thing, basically.
LOUIS GRAY: You know, you
mentioned Arab Spring.
You know, this is in,
I think, 2011.
There's a big explosion of
activity in that area.
And one of the weapons that
the government had was to
discontinue the information
coming in and the
communication going out.
And I think it's really
remarkable to think about
being part of that story.
Not just covering it, but
actually legitimately having
information being used as a
weapon by a government against
or for its own people.
And so, as you start to take
a look at that Transparency
Report, it almost becomes a
living history on its own.
You see specific countries
that have taken action--
be it China, be it Egypt,
be it Syria--
and it starts to really tell
a very interesting story.
At what point did it become, for
your team, something that
evolved from just an
informational perspective to
recognizing it's like a living
history that we can publish?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: I think it
was after the Arab Spring hit
that we realized--
because when we switched from a
35-hour delay to two minute
delay, we were no longer
reporting in the news.
We were participating in the
event, which is a really
interesting place to be.
But then, as we started to see
these piling up, we thought,
hey, we need a better way to
show this, which led to what
we call our disruption view.
So you can sort of see
disruptions that are ongoing,
disruptions that happened
last year, or the
year before, et cetera.
It gives you a feel for
where outages are
happening around the world.
LOUIS GRAY: Well, we talked a
little bit about the what, but
I want to go back to the why.
Like, why is this
thing even here?
There's really no legal guidance
telling Google that
we have to show this
information.
Is that right?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: No.
LOUIS GRAY: So we
don't have to.
So why are we doing this
in the first place?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, it
comes back to its in our
business interest to show when
access to our products are
restricted, because if people
can't get to Google products,
we can't not only service
people, but
we don't make money.
LOUIS GRAY: Are we turning the
tables around a little bit,
saying, hey, it's not
our fault that you
can't get to this.
It's your government's fault.
Or is this just something where
we need to have people
understand why they can't get
something, or why we want
other people to understand
why a specific
country can't get something.
Is it kind of a comment
on the world view?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, It's
not about really comprehension
and understanding.
We leave that to the press
to describe what's
going on and why.
It's more about, hey, this is a
simple, factual change that
we've seen, and this is
what's happening.
I can't reach-- for example,
Pakistan shut off YouTube last
year, and it's an
ongoing outage.
And so--
LOUIS GRAY: You're saying
Pakistan can't be watching
this right now.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Right.
There's probably--
LOUIS GRAY: Maybe if they get
that resolved, then in a
couple years, they'll
watch this and
understand why it happened.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Exactly.
So there's that.
And it's important, I think,
for people to know
what's going on.
That's, I think, the core issue
around transparency, is
showing people what's
going on.
And then either research their
own conclusions, draw their
own conclusions, or in the case
of the press, reporters
writing up articles using other
sources to verify what's
going on and showing more
information about the context
of the outage.
LOUIS GRAY: And I think you and
I have talked about this
before, the transparency,
we call it a core
value here at Google.
It's part of who we are.
And sometimes I get pushback
from people
don't believe that.
You know, hey, you guys are just
in it for the money or
for the data.
So why should users believe that
transparency is part of
what we do?
Isn't it like a used car
salesman saying, trust me,
this is the best deal.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, I'm
kind of a believer in trust,
but verify.
I think the real issue is that
it's not-- again, transparency
is almost a little bit
of a misnomer.
It's about accountability.
It's about showing this is the
information that we have.
Only we have all the information
about access to
our products.
So I think it's in our benefit
to show what's going on,
because it makes it more obvious
when something happens
and this changes.
LOUIS GRAY: You gave a couple
of examples of products that
are impacted.
You started with Blogger.
You mentioned YouTube as
being two specific
services that are impacted.
Are there other services which
are popular blocks?
Are there things that
Google sees most
likely to be taken down?
And why is it that those
specific ones are targeted
versus something like Google
Search or Gmail?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well,
I think that
they're publishing platforms.
I think that's why.
I think that's why YouTube
and Blogger are
probably the biggest.
In some places, photos
are blocked as well.
But it's platforms that people
can use to publish.
And if you're in a country
that doesn't have a free
press, or you have a press
that's very much
government-controlled, then you
don't want this sort of
free distribution platform
out there.
And I think it's perceived as
a danger by a lot of people.
LOUIS GRAY: Sure.
And now, moving a little bit
away from the traffic report,
we do have a lot of transparency
in terms of
governments that are getting
in the way of our services.
There's also a lot of requests
that come from
governments on user data.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Correct.
LOUIS GRAY: Can you take me
through that and help us
understand what it is that
we can share via the
Transparency Report?
Obviously, it's been
very hot recently.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Right.
So there's data that
we can share.
So we get court orders.
We get warrants for information,
typically for
criminal cases.
Someone's done something bad.
The government's looking for
evidence in a case against
them, and they send
us a request.
And there's a process that
it goes through.
Someone doesn't just call us up
and say, hey, send us all
the data on Louis Gray.
And if they do that,
we say come back
with a warrant, basically.
They come back with a warrant,
and they say, send us, you
know, everyone in the world
who's searched for this thing.
We would say, well, that's
overly broad.
Can you be more specific?
And then they rewrite the
warrant to say, we just want
information on Louis Gray.
Typically, it's something like
subscriber information.
They're going to want your name,
your address, and IP
addresses you've
logged in from.
And again, we're interested in
helping with criminal cases.
We want to help catch
the bad guys.
We just want to make sure that
the requests are legal, that
they're not overly broad, and
that we are actually helping
catch the bad guys and
not just giving a
bunch of data away.
LOUIS GRAY: And there's a lot
of requests that we actually
can't talk about.
I think that those have flared
up in the press of late, and
some things have
been disclosed.
To the best of our ability, what
are we doing about that?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, with
NSL, National Security
Letters, is a good one.
If you look at the government
request site, you'll see that
we talked about-- we received
so many requests from a
government for information that
affected this many users,
and we complied with this
percentage of the request, in
full or part.
And there's some things like
the NSLs, National Security
Letters, that up until May, we
couldn't even acknowledged we
got, because they came
with a gag order.
And that was a legal requirement
that we couldn't
acknowledge that we
got these things.
And we went back and forth with
the government to say,
hey, we think it's important
to publicly
state that we got these.
LOUIS GRAY: And you're speaking
specifically about
the US government.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: US
government, right, because
we're a US company.
So these national security
letters, we finally got the
ability to talk about the
fact that we get them in
magnitudes of 1,000.
So last year, we had
1,000 of these
National Security Letters.
They affected, I think it
was 0 to 1,000 users.
So we get 0 to 1,000 letters
affecting 0 to 1,000 or 1,000
or 2,000 or something
like that.
And so people say, we
want more specifics.
And again, we don't want to
endanger any ongoing criminal
investigations, but
it would be great
to have more specifics.
But I think that the fact that
we can admit we got these at
all is a huge step forward.
And I'm really happy
about that.
Now the thing that's
come this summer is
the FISA court, right?
And we have filed, I believe, a
suit against the FISA court
to be able to disclose this
information, if, in fact,
we've gotten any requests
from this court.
We can't acknowledge
if we have or if we
haven't at this point.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
And that's something, obviously,
you kind of have to
wait and see.
The courts aren't the fastest
things in the world by
definition.
I think when you talk about
this, we are fighting for this
with the expectation that we
can deliver information for
our users so they better
understand that when they use
our services that their data
is in a safe place and that
we're not going to do anything
with malfeasance.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: The other
thing that we're interested in
is that this information shows
government requests for user's
data, a lot of this, in the
United States at least, falls
under the Electronic
Communication
Protection Act of 1986.
Now this was a law written about
technical issues back in
1986, when the world wide web
didn't exist and there weren't
things like web-based email,
or that sort of thing.
So some of this is that we want
to show all the data so
you can see what's going on.
And then maybe the next law
that affects this type of
information might be a little
different, might be a little
more appropriate given the
current state of affairs,
where you're not keeping
all your mail on a
machine at your house.
LOUIS GRAY: Sure.
And I think, going back to that
a little bit, that was a
law that was written 25-plus
years ago at this point.
So Google can almost play a
role in shaping the law or
giving direction to knowing how
much companies can share
and should share, but possibly
recommend how we have a new
approach to user data or
transparency as well.
It sounds like we could
possibly-- you know, lobbying
goes on or do something
about that.
Is that right?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Right.
I mean, we've seen a lot of
other companies putting this
information out there, but I'd
like to see the government
themselves providing
this information.
LOUIS GRAY: Now, stepping
to another tab.
We've got a lot going on in
the Transparency Report.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Sure.
LOUIS GRAY: One thing that often
comes up is requests for
removal, you know, be it
individuals or legal agencies,
they ask for data
that's in Google
Search index to be removed.
Like, hey, stop showing
sites from URL X.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Right.
LOUIS GRAY: Can you take
us through that?
I think there's really two
parts, first of which is
removing it from the index.
And the second is someone
saying, there's something on a
Google service that I would
like to have taken down.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Right.
It could be a blog post.
It could be a YouTube video.
It could be a photo.
It could be a link in
the search index.
We get a lot of these removal
requests, and there's two
types of removal requests
we get.
The first one is like, as you
said, government requests.
And most of these are
defamation, and then beyond
that it's privacy and security
issues that we were required
to remove to basically
conform to the law.
And some of these are like,
clearly, like public safety.
Not public safety issues, but
it might endanger something.
For example, someone posts a
picture and some information
about a child.
Like, clearly, this isn't
information that should be
publicly accessible.
So that we have a process
for requesting that that
information be removed, and
they have a process
for taking it down.
LOUIS GRAY: And in this case,
when you get that kind of
request, it's not Google who's
making a decision whether it's
defamation or not.
You're basically taking
an order from a court
that says, do this.
And we comply if it's legal and
within the right scope.
Is that--
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
That's correct.
LOUIS GRAY: OK.
So--
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: We don't want
to be in the business of
making these decisions.
We think a court should be
making these decision.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
Absolutely.
Now, one thing-- if I take a
look at this report, if I go
specifically to removal
requests, the dramatic rise in
the URLs expected to be removed
from Search, it seems
like it's up about 300% in the
last year, year and a half.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, you're
talking about copyright
requests now.
So another kind of removal
requests are DNC takedowns.
And we publish all
of our takedowns
we get for web search.
And we launched this product
in May of 2012.
And at the time we were getting
about 1.5 million
requests a month to remove URLs,
1.5 million URLs removed
from our index every month.
And as I checked this morning,
I think we're up to
18 million a month.
LOUIS GRAY: 18,047,340.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Yeah,
that's a lot.
And we update that every day.
But this is, again, to show--
so when you search for something
on Google and don't
find it, many people assume it
doesn't exist on the internet.
And our point is that
it may be out there.
We just have been required
to remove a link to it.
And we're not out to help
people find potentially
infringing information
on the internet.
But we do want to show that
there's a sort of what we call
a negative search space.
And so this is a way of
showing, here are the
rights-holders sending
us takedown requests.
Here are the agencies
representing them sending us
the takedowns, in some cases.
And lastly, the websites who are
receiving the potentially
infringing requests as well.
So it's a way of showing
these things because--
the reason I think it's
important so this is websites,
unlike someone who posts a
YouTube video or writes a
blog, we don't always have a way
to contact these people.
So we have no way of
definitively letting you know,
if you have a website on the
internet, that we've received
a takedown to pull you out of
our index so that you can do a
counter takedown request.
LOUIS GRAY: This is something
that's interesting.
One of the things that I
always assumed prior to
working here is that Google
has access to just about
everything.
Like, don't you have enough
resources to do X or Y?
But now that we're here, you
take a look at something like
18 million URLs that have been
requested to be removed.
That's got to be an incredible
processing process.
How do you go ahead
and do that?
How do you set up that thing?
But in addition to that, you
take a look at this page, and
we even have a list of recently
submitted URLs where
we did nothing.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Right.
LOUIS GRAY: And there's probably
a reason for that,
which you can take me through.
But I assume that basically
shows, here's our process.
We don't accept every single
one that was requested.
That some get through.
Some don't.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: We comply
with a very large percentage.
I don't know the exact number,
but I would say we comply with
most of them.
But sometimes we get takedown
requests that are invalid.
Or sometimes they're mistaken.
We get requests from a
rights-holder to take down
links to their own website
in some cases.
LOUIS GRAY: I've seen that.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: We get
requests from individuals who
have had, let's say, for
example, some press on the web
that they don't like.
They send us takedown requests,
which are invalid,
because they don't own the
copyright on that information.
So this is just a way of showing
a little bit, some of
the things that are happening,
because, while most of them
are correct, there is always
an opportunity,
I think, for abuse.
But there really isn't
very much of it.
LOUIS GRAY: So we talked
about the vast number
of copyright requests.
We talked about governments who
make specific requests to
make these changes.
We talked about which common
Google services there are that
have these interruptions.
So if you have a product that
actually is disrupted--
let's take a look at a specific
geographic region.
Does that mean absolutely
nobody in that
region can use it?
Or is it like really slow
dial-up speeds, and they might
be able to get it, but it's not
going to be a lot of fun?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
It means that--
it depends on what the
disruption shows.
Like because the graph can show
a partial disruption or a
full disruption.
LOUIS GRAY: What's
partial mean?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Partial means
that, like let's say a
country has 10 ISPs, and they
cut off six of them.
So four ISPs in the country may
still be serving traffic
to their users.
So it may be that a certain
percentage of the country
can't access their services.
When it's all the way down to
zero, that means that almost
everyone can't.
And there may be the odd person
who's got a satellite
connection or something, which
are illegal in some places.
Or they may be getting
information
through their cell phone.
You don't know.
There's always a few people
that may be getting the
information.
It also may mean that our IP
to Geo mapping is off.
So there may be a corner
case, somewhere
that's getting something.
There's no way to know
for certain.
LOUIS GRAY: There's one thing
that you-- you actually
introduced it this summer
about safe browsing.
I think most of us have used the
internet, whether we use
Chrome or Firefox or other
browsers, sometimes you run
into something on Google search
where it says, hey,
this website might be harmful
to your computer.
So let's talk about this.
We looked at the numbers.
And I'm really curious about the
way that we would be able
to handle 18 million
URL requests.
But I assume that the vast
spidering and taking a look at
all these URLs to find out,
not only what content they
have for search results, but to
know that they're safe for
you computer, it's got to
be incredibly intensive.
What do we display?
How do we warn people about
what's there and
provide safe browsing?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, first
of all, we don't let them go
straight to the website.
So if you're in Google Search
and you click on a site that
has malware on it, we take you
to an interstitial page that
says, hey, this site may
harm your computer.
We don't make it easy
for you to go there.
But let me back up to what
actually happens in a lot of
these cases.
Because a lot of times, these
sites with harmful information
aren't a scary site.
It might be some new site
you visit all the time.
It might be someone's
blog or something.
What happens is that
there are malware
providers on the internet.
They're hosting malware.
They're trying to
do bad things.
They're trying to get control of
your computer to send spam
email, or do something
not cool.
LOUIS GRAY: Known bad actors.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
Known bad actors.
Thank you.
And so what they do in a lot
of cases is they'll go and
they will break into a website
that's popular, and they will
put malware on that website so
that when you go to that
website, your computer will
download that malware.
And then your computer suddenly
is going to be
controlled by them.
LOUIS GRAY: In that case, you
basically have a victim that
is passing it on.
They've been infected,
and they want to
infect you as well.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Right.
LOUIS GRAY: And they might
not have done anything
intentionally.
But their site is definitely
infected.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: And
many times, they
don't even know it.
So that's another scary thing,
is that if you're not paying
attention going to your website,
it might have been
broken into.
Malware may be hosted.
You just don't know it.
LOUIS GRAY: I think sometimes
those people who run in the
internet, you'll see a search
result for a well-known blog
or tech site you
regularly read.
And then the description of
the site will be all about
selling pharmaceutical
drugs at low cost.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Right.
LOUIS GRAY: Which is one
example of that.
So first of all, let's talk
about that, like-- not the
pharmaceutical drugs.
That's a different show.
But to talk about making the web
safer, first again, why is
Google doing this?
What is it that we're doing to
accurately find out if a site
is hosting malware or not?
And then, what can we do to
either protect the users or
the site hosts themselves?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, the
reason we're doing this is
because we do well if more
people use the web.
And if more people are using
the web and having terrible
things happen to them and their
computers, fewer people
are going to use the web.
And so it's in our best interest
to make sure that
people are safe on the web
using our products.
If you know that you can go to
Google Search and that we're
going to protect you from
malware wherever we can, I
think that encourages you to
come use us more often.
If you came to Google and used
Google Search to find a
website and you clicked
through-- even if it was a
popular tech blog--
and then it gave you malware,
I don't know that you'd
necessarily-- you may
blame Google.
You may not.
But still, I don't think
you'd be happy.
It's a bad experience for
you overall, and we
helped you get there.
So I think it's in our best
interest to do that.
And we'll also try and notify
webmasters through our
Webmaster Tools, if you signed
up with that, that your site
is infected.
So that's why it's a great--
if you have a website,
Webmaster Tools is
a great resource.
It's free.
It tells you a ton of
information about your site,
and it will keep you up
to date if we find
anything wrong with it.
LOUIS GRAY: Now taking a look at
these graphs in the Making
the Web Safer category in the
Transparency Report, again we
see another rise in
the total numbers.
When you look at this, it says,
"Upwards of 300 million
users see browser warnings every
single week." And that's
significant.
That's practically the entire
population of the United
States alone.
And so I assume some of those
are individuals seeing
multiple warnings per week.
Or is that one per?
I don't know how it's done.
But that's about triple where
it was just 12 months ago.
What do we think is
causing that?
Do we have any idea to
understand why you have that
kind of rise in malware
tripping?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: I think
there's an ebb
and a flow to it.
And we see people finding new
vulnerabilities in websites
that they can exploit and
upload their malware.
And so, we've had peaks
in the past that have
gone down as well.
I'm not sure what the rise in
that is attributable to, but
what we've done in the malware
report is we've divided up
where the malware is hosted, in
many cases by what we call
autonomous network, so that
you can see sort of like
people who are responsible for
a particular block of IP
addresses on the web.
So that you can see--
in some cases, if you look
at the dashboard--
where some of this is hosted.
And some places have more
things than others.
We're hoping that people will
look at that as an opportunity
to clean up their garden,
so to speak, and
keep their yard clean.
LOUIS GRAY: Sure.
So when we look at the
Transparency Report, we've got
multiple tabs here.
We've got the Traffic report,
Removal Requests report, User
Data Requests, and
Safe Browsing.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: A
lot of stuff now.
LOUIS GRAY: We talked a little
bit about why we do it.
Let's go back to the
very beginning of
launching this thing.
How did you get that
to happen?
You know, I think--
interesting discussions that
we've had in the last two
days, talking about the
Liberation Front, organization
manipulation.
It seems like you probably had
to manipulate the organization
a little bit to enable them
to make this information
available to our users.
How did you go about championing
that for Google?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, the
interesting thing about the
Transparency Report, I didn't.
The Transparency Report was
started by a bunch of 20%
people from the legal side--
LOUIS GRAY: What is 20%?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: The 20% is
the ability to sometimes take
up to 20% of your time to work
on something else other than
your main project that's
in Google's interest.
So don't go off and, like,
practice your painting skills.
But go off and work on another
piece of software or another
project that's--
LOUIS GRAY: So it's like a
part-time project in addition
to their full-time job?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Yeah.
It's like something you think's
important or something
you'd like to check out,
that kind of thing.
And so we had a lot of--
we had legal.
We had PR.
We had Policy and Engineering
working on this and they
initially launched the traffic
in the government requests
thing, and it was being
maintained and run out of just
a sort of ragtag band
of 20% folks.
And I talked to my friend, Matt,
who's currently the tech
lead for the Transparency
Report.
And when he sort of briefed me
on what they were doing, I was
floored that this wasn't
a full-time team.
And it seemed incredibly
important.
So I went and talked to a couple
of our execs, and I
said, look, this seems
really important.
I'd love to build a real,
full-time engineering team to
not only maintain this, but to
improve it and continue to
find more interesting data sets
and interesting products
that we can build to show people
what's going on and how
freedom of expression is being
affected on the internet.
And their response was,
that sounds awesome.
Go for it.
And so then I basically--
I pulled Matt in as the tech
lead, and hired a few more
people, and we've got a
fantastic team, just like Data
Liberation.
It's a small team of dedicated
engineers who are really at
the top of their game.
And we poke around Google and
see what kind of things we
can't dig up and publish to not
only show what's going on,
but we often have a goal that we
want to sort of make things
a little better, right?
We're publishing the
traffic graphs.
We hope that people realize that
they're not going to get
away with it.
People are going to know very
clearly that they're shutting
out traffic.
So maybe they'll think
twice about it.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
And I think one thing that
people often talk about is the
percentage of web
traffic that's
through Google's services.
And as we start to be a
significant portion of that,
when you cut access to the web,
we're going to see it.
And since we have the
Transparency Report, your
users are going to see it.
The press is going to see it.
I think one of the adages that
we've always learned from Eric
Schmidt and Larry Page is, you
don't fight against the web.
The web always wins.
I think this has been a very
cool discussion, talking about
the Transparency Report, and
really how the web and its
services are being used to
push change, be it with
governments that want to keep
things a certain way and the
status quo.
But they are affecting the
people on the ground who want
to have that information,
have that communication.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: My closing
thought I'll give you is that,
never before in the history of
mankind has-- or humankind--
has there been a global
distribution system that costs
almost nothing.
And that is what makes the
internet so amazing.
And I'm a big fan.
LOUIS GRAY: I'm glad you're
looking out for us, and
looking out for users.
So thanks again for coming
in for all three
parts of Fitz Week--
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
My pleasure.
LOUIS GRAY: --Brian.
It's been a lot of fun.
For those of you watching,
definitely take a look at
google.com/transparencyreport.
This has been Google
Developers Live.
I'm Louis Gray, and we'll see
you back in the studio.
[MUSIC PLAYING]